[Aplausos]
tan muy serios algunos
vengo a compartirles hoy un poco de mi
corazón no de mis palabras de mi corazón
y mi corazón tiene forma de huevo
ahorita van a entender por qué yo les
vengo a hablar del poder sanador del
arte porque todos absolutamente todos
nacemos artistas nacemos desde que
estamos en el vientre de nuestra madre y
escuchamos las primeras melodías niños
ustedes que están allá
me ven todos ustedes son artistas ya lo
sabían no sabían ok papá si me escuchas
dónde estás
tu papá también eres artista y tú
sandino también eres artista gracias por
escucharme todos nacemos artistas
y estas son fotos de los hijos de mis
amigos o de mis amigos cuando eran
pequeños aquí ven caras conocidas
estos niños creativos que tenemos entre
nosotros oa lo mejor nosotros estamos en
alguna de esas fotos haciendo arte sin
ninguna inhibición
hay espacios para estos niños creativos
en la paz hay espacios para que ellos
vayan a hacer pintura performance música
danza aérea literatura teatro diseño
pintura hay espacios para ellos por eso
me interesó tanto
crear un proyecto para fomentar la
cultura y su poder sanador y la y el
arte por supuesto y vamos a recordar a
este hombre we sing a un investigador
holandés y filósofo este hombre nació el
mismo día que yo
y escribió un libro que se llama el homo
ludens homo ludens es el humano que
juega
no solo el homo sapiens y no solo el
homo faber el que piensa y el que
fabrica también el que juega y en
nuestras ciudades que nos está olvidando
jugar vamos todos muy serios por la
calle y en nuestros espacios de trabajo
todos olvidamos crear olvidamos que
somos niños creadores crecimos y dejamos
al niño creador del lado
el arte es una forma natural de aprender
tú no puedes separar la clase de arte de
la vida la vida es el arte y el arte es
la vida
bien lo sabía picazo desde niño pintó su
primer cuadro a los 8 años con la ayuda
de su papá y luego creció y se convirtió
en un niño grandote que siempre nos deja
con la boca abierta con lo que hace este
hombre dice que todos nacemos artistas
lo difícil es seguir siéndolo cuando
crecemos
el arte es una forma de comunicación yo
me comunico conmigo misma a través del
arte me conecto con mis raíces con mi
fuente espiritual y con todo mi entorno
el arte es parte de la comunicación
humana y no lo podemos dejar de lado y
no lo podemos excluir de ningún programa
ni de ningún proyecto una un autor un
pintor un escultor un bailarín propone
algo aquí está mi hijo en una galería
estábamos viendo escultura vean su cara
vean lo que quiso decir el artista el
artista todos lo conocemos aquí en la
paz baja california sur se los voy a
dejar de tarea quien es y mi hijo
tuvo una reacción a eso que el artista
quiso comunicar y solo mi hijo conoce
esa reacción que tuvo el arte nos
conecta con nosotros el artista de un
mensaje y nosotros entendemos lo que
queremos y lo que podemos
como las pinturas rupestres el hombre
desde la prehistoria ha comunicado
mensajes a través del arte
este cuadro que hizo mi mamá con
recortes fue lo que yo vi todos los días
al desayunar al comer y al cenar de
alguna forma se quedó en mi inconsciente
y yo cuando crecí quise ser diseñadora
diseñadora
si se fijan este es un eclipse a simple
vista alguien ve algo más aparte de un
eclipse
si ven algo más
un agujero
yo les voy a invitar a que abran su
imaginación y se imaginen que ese
agujero está en esa pared imaginaria que
ponen entre las personas normales y
entre los artistas donde dividimos
ponemos una línea estos son artistas y
estos son personas normales vamos a ver
por ese hoyo vamos a ver que hay allá
adentro
2013 yo en una gran depresión este
dibujo yo lo hice para tratar de
expresar cómo me sentía en este momento
de sequía creativa y espiritual
la luna y yo ya no nos hablábamos
empecé a dibujar dije voy a poner en
papel cómo me siento y estos dibujos
fueron sacando poco a poco mis
sensaciones mis emociones y me empezaron
a sanar
hasta que llegó esa flor maravillosa una
enredadera que está en todas las
ciudades de la paz que se llama
llamarada según mi papá es una
enredadera verde con ojos con flores muy
naranjas si la conocen bueno se llena en
el verano de esa flor cuando está lo más
duro del verano y yo veía la la
enredadera y tomaba fuerza de sus
colores de ese naranja tan fuerte de ese
verde tan vivo
y yo
de alguna manera hice una poesía
dedicada a esta flor y se las voy a
compartir
el día brillante
y yo nublada
nublada por bilis verde y amarilla
llamarada
botones de flores cortadas
este poema
fue una medicina para mí estuve leyendo
muchos libros de poesía y me salió esa
poesía creo que el arte es medicina y
que todos debemos de tomarla
sin querer regañarlos verdad todos
deberíamos tomar la medicina del arte
esta estas imágenes era lo que había a
mi alrededor cuando yo estaba deprimida
huracan audi
empecé a crear diseños
no sé si ya vieron estas imágenes en
algún lugar
pero fue una explosión de mi ser
creativo de mi niña interior que quería
salir a jugar
hice todo esto
con el fin de curarme y después me di
cuenta que no solo me estaba curando yo
sola también se estaba curando mi
entorno y la sociedad que me rodeaba
esta instalación en espacio público
donde yo pude comunicar una idea y
protestar que estaba en contra de la
minería tóxica esta fue mi manera de
hacerlo
la vida es un juego
me fui curando me fui limpiando fui
haciendo catarsis
me sane como mujer sane la relación con
mi madre
sane la relación con mi niña interior
y punto salió un huevo
un sueño colectivo en forma de huevo
casa cultural el huevo el huevo es un
sueño colectivo el huevo es el cascarón
que envuelve la vida
hemos trabajado 538 días para la
comunidad para los artistas y por los
artistas nadie que ha ido al huevo a
nuestro espacio le hemos dicho que no
todos los artistas que han querido estar
allí se han presentado ahí y ustedes que
esperan los estoy esperando
278 eventos en un año y medio y esto no
fue magia fue el trabajo de mi familia
mi trabajo el trabajo de los voluntarios
esporádicos que de repente nos lleve
llegan y el trabajo de toda la comunidad
porque la renta no se paga sola lo
hacemos entre todos y los invito a que
toda la ciudad se llene de huevos de
huevos creadores porque los necesitamos
niños quieren que les pongan un huevo en
su escuela
ya saben lo que es el huevo bueno los
voy a invitar saliendo de aquí
fíjense vamos a crear juntos los
artistas quedan expuesto con nosotros
son artistas la mayoría nuevos que nunca
habían tenido una exposición porque
porque creemos que todos nacemos
artistas y tú no le puedes decir que no
a ninguna expresión artística y creativa
muchos se centran en la pintura ah eres
artista pintas pero no fíjense todo lo
que puedes hacer en el arte esta es una
lista de todas las manifestaciones
artísticas que existen y de cada línea
sale una gran ramificación
y si no existe tú la puedes inventar
quienes ya están haciendo arte pueden
levantar su mano
ok
el 10% muy bien esa carita feliz es para
ustedes qué bueno los felicito y los que
todavía no se animan yo los invito esa
carita triste es porque me da tristeza
que habiendo tantas cosas que hacer no
lo estamos haciendo porque no lo hacemos
vamos a hacerlo
vamos a ver por ese hueco y ver qué hay
detrás de esa pared
sea un cómplice de los artistas los
artistas siempre necesitan cómplices y
te invito a que tú seas el cómplice de
un artista o que busques cómplices para
crear o para proyectar tu trabajo
crea tu propio espacio de juego si no
tienes dónde jugar inventa lo tú
hagamos del arte una prioridad el arte
es parte del ser humano y debe ser lo
más importante para mí para desarrollar
una sociedad sana
se una autodidacta si no sabes hacerlo
aprende
y busca la forma de aprenderlo con tus
propios medios
pégate a los maestros si conoces un
maestro que admiras
ofrece té a lavarle los pinceles a cómo
darle su bodega
y ellos no te van a decir que no todos
los maestros están buscando aprendices
toca puertas si no sabes por dónde ponte
a tocar puertas algunas se te va a abrir
juega en equipo todos los que hemos
hablado somos un gran equipo si no
trabajamos en equipo no vamos a poder
hacer de esta ciudad un gran huevo que
rompe su cascarón y llenar te llena todo
el mundo de arte
fórmate como un profesional si quieres
hacerlo estudia hazlo bien
date permiso de experimentar
ya no te tomes tan en serio equivocarte
riega la experimenta no pasa nada
y como dice alice walker feminista
afroamericana si el arte no nos hace
mejores entonces para qué sirve vamos a
este sueño colectivo de creación
voy a terminar con esto
imaginemos que estos dos capullos que
están en la pantalla son dos seres que
están a punto de nacer
porque en la vida
nacemos dos veces la primera vez
es cuando nuestra madre
nos da luz
y la segunda
es cuando nosotros nos damos salud a
nosotros mismos y el arte puede ayudarte
a tener una armoniosa y catártica labor
de parto y en cuanto a mí yo te deseo
que en el mundo del arte tengas un
magnífico nacimiento muchas gracias
[Aplausos]